[Applause]
crazy crazy put put your tops back
on except you grandmother all right it's
Friday so you know what that means let's
welcome tonight's guests he's married to
another Dave which saves on monogram
towels host of the Ruben report Dave
Reuben he was voted sexy man alive by
certified public accountants magazine
Fox News contributor Charlie
herd She's still full from the Crouton
she ate last week New York Times
bestselling author foxus contributor
ctip and he's got a lot of influence
over helicopter flight routes New York
Times bestselling author comedian former
NWA world champion
title all
right before we get to some news try to
ignore my new glasses let's do
this Greg's
leftovers Lego man all right it's
leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck we'll nail Joe Mackey to a wall and
throw axes at his
head all right scientists in China have
been reportedly been able to keep a
cloned monkey alive for 2 years that's
nothing we kept ours alive for
monkey this week Green Day performed a
surprise set in New York Subway along
with tonight's show host Jimmy Fallon
commuters shouted requests like please
stop
yeah a source in Hollywood would said a
movie about Harvard's plagiarizing
former president Claudine gay has
Academy Award written all over it though
on closer inspection it was in Gay's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
handwriting whenever I see her Tyrus I
think of the Humpty
Dance wow I know a new study shows that
men do have better navigational skills
than women sadly most women don't even
know about this study because they went
to the wrong
website
Charlie oh Charlie's a
sexist a new study shows that by the
year 2100 many US cities will be
completely populated by the elderly
which means the late night shift at
strip clubs will end at 4
p.m. in a new court filing the doj
determined a white substance found on
Hunter's Biden's gun was likely to be
cocaine prompting Hunter to ask when he
could get his gun
[Laughter]
back he likes
Coke Chinese scientist say they've
created a new strain of Corona virus
that kills by attacking the brain guess
I'm safe said one
[Laughter]
woman little
thank you thank you a woman went viral
after revealing she makes six figures
milking cows while wearing bikinis
doesn't make any sense why would you
make a cow wear a
bikini it's a little clean joke for the
kids a few Madonna fans have filed a
class action lawsuit because she keeps
starting her shows late although to be
fair her face does arrive an hour early
yeah officials in Florida say a woman
used dog urine to try to beat a drug
test someone should have told her she
didn't have to drink it
first this week Joy bear said struggling
members of Generation Z need to shut up
and get a job speaking of the view is
looking for applicants to toss buckets
of raw sardines during Joy's 12:00
feeding
time the board of Ben and Jerry's has
demanded a permanent ceasefire in Gaza
after all they prefer people to die
slowly from obesity related
diseases that one
sticks some Target and Walmart stores
are now locking up underwear and socks
as part of a shop lifting Crackdown
raising the question who has to shoplift
underwear in
socks Kim Kardashian is selling her
smash 2022 Range Rover for
$100,000 it comfortably sits eight
people or one giant
ass the language we have here according
to a new study a common mistake people
make after sex is looking at their phone
for any missed messages especially if
the message is close your
[Laughter]
blinds Hugh Hefner's iconic red velvet
smoking jacket is going up for auction
the lucky buyer will also receive
[Laughter]
Gara you gave up
halfway I love that joke D I'm going to
be honest I still want the jacket
and finally last Saturday during a pro
Palestinian protest at the White House
many protesters chanted F Joe Biden
trust me it's overrated said one
woman now to the
news thank you all
right more
Applause is our Navy sinking with Dei
thinking it's time
for it's coming your way hey hey it's of
the
day today's video of the day comes to us
from Dr Charles Chuck Barber the ex
director of the Navy's diversity equity
and inclusion programs an old training
video is resurfaced and it's more
disturbing than the top drawer of Larry
cow's night
stand Barber May no longer be there but
the Navy still has a program dedicated
to Dei even as corporations and
candidates are ditching this poisonous
process like it's one a Jimmy fail is
jackets
wow very touchy I know wow don't make
fun of Jimmy's jackets in fact it's
still up there on the Navy website watch
how he explains
Dei what exactly is thei so let's just
take a few seconds just to define those
very briefly diversity which is the
presence of difference within our
Workforce Equity when you think about
Equity you also need to think about
equality because those terms are often
used interchangeably so when you think
about equality which is the instate we
that we want to achieve or the quality
of outcomes think about Equity as the
the route that we take to get there how
do we assess those different barriers
and access to information to ensure that
we all have the equal um access to that
outcome we that we want to achieve then
inclusion is just spring that culture of
belonging how do we ensure that that our
entire Workforce is able to thrive and
develop in the current environment what
the hell was
that I mean you said you were going to
explain it in a few seconds I have no
idea what you just said and you're the
expert it's like somebody poured a zema
all over chat gbt's
motherboard in that mess of Gog he says
however that Equity is the path to
equality which is complete and utter
Equity is the opposite of equality
equality is about opportunity Equity is
about outcomes and if you control for
outcomes you eliminate opportunity in
short equality is about the starting
line where we all start with the same
chance Equity starts at the Finish Line
where we all land in the same spot and
work backwards how easy is that equality
is possible Equity is impossible look at
it this way equality is putting me en
Tyrus into a wrestling ring and watching
me
die Equity Equity is putting me in Tyrus
into a wrestling ring with me wearing an
Iron Man suit equipped with laser guns
and still watching me
die it's literally impossible to create
equal outcomes in a universe of
individuals that's why you rarely see a
virtual will tie in a foot race Dei is
the most anti-individualist Endeavor
ever for it assumes that there's no
diversity among individual talents which
is why they hamper Excellence by
promoting mediocrity and now we're
preaching this crap in the greatest
military on the planet why don't we just
turn the keys to the Pacific Fleet over
to the Chinese right now this is
supposed to be the only place left that
depends on meritocracy but then again if
you look around the rest of the
America's storied institutions we've
ditched that gold standard so why should
the military be any different look I
just want the deadliest military on
Earth not the most diverse I don't care
if our soldiers are straight I just want
them to shoot
straight
period Dave it's see it's so weird
because what we're seeing right now is
everybody running from Dei even
Democratic candidates are running from
it and yet this is still up on the Navy
website does this scare you Greg I will
talk about that but can we talk about
your glasses first CU you you look like
a middle-aged lesbian
poet which which actually might be Dei
for Fox because I I am now a diverse
hire I identify as I don't even know the
name like a furry jacket and these big
glasses you know what I mean you'd be in
the in the lesbian poetry places yes I'm
thinking of now getting a few
cats little like Rosie odonnell actually
yes I feel like Rosie O'Donnell in this
show
wow they're they're very touchy on their
references I know I know uh no look they
don't like talking about anybody who's
not here Dei is as you laid out it it is
the reverse of everything that America
was founded upon which of course is a
quality of opportunity and nobody the
thing is nobody in America cares about
this stuff except the people that are
bludgeoning us with it and until we just
get back to not caring about whether
your doctor is black or white or your
pilot is Black or White if we're going
to care about that we're going to have
an awful lot of planes falling out of
the sky and we're going to have a lot of
doctors that don't know how to perform
surgery and that would be problematic
but also it be a lot of fun be like a
Russian Roulette whatever in everything
you do my theory Charlie is Dei is going
to maintain its kind of Survival by
filling the spaces in the Dei
departments with Dei hires you see what
I mean it's the what do you call the
self-licking ice cream cone well yeah
but you want it to be fun like on a
college campus that's where you can have
fun you know where you can't have fun in
the military and like your point uh is
the most important one which is you know
the military was sort of like this hold
out yeah it never you it was all about m
and could you perform the mission and it
was such a wonderful place because it it
rung out all of the differences that
humans like make up because all that
mattered was mission and this guy I I
mean as you point out my man here can he
doesn't even know the actual
definitional difference between equity
and equality and then he goes on to lie
about how it uh uh CLA he claims that it
helps everything but but this also goes
to euphemisms euphemisms destroy
anything that's important the Department
of Defense should go back to being the
department of War so that everybody is
clear that's what this is about that
sounds so much better Department war and
it's also a war it's a warning too that
we're not doing this to like Nation
build we're doing this to kill you yes
and and remind everybody I think
everybody would be happy with if I were
president I would start the department
of War go back to it it was originally
the department of war and then somebody
wanting euphemisms wanting it to soften
it down decided to rename it Department
of Defense I'm going to trust you on
that that would be really funny if you
made that up
you know cat I'm okay with Dei at Old
Navy but I'm not okay with it I'm not
okay with it at our Navy oh I got it our
Navy see what I did there I went from
old to hour just changed two letters you
had it Gutfeld don't explain
it you had it you won the
day cat please continue yeah uh well
first of all Go Army
[Laughter]
wow uh but I there's also this idea
right that individualism is every man
for himself kind of thing when it's
actually the opposite of that right
because if we're all which is obviously
reality as you pointed out we're all
individuals with different strengths
different weaknesses acknowledging that
is a greater argument for needing to
work together than anything else would
be because if everyone's exactly as good
as everyone else is at everything then
you would never need anybody's help
right so individualism is not every man
for self it's more acknowledging what
your strengths are and maybe what your
weaknesses are and someone else can help
you that's really what it is if you
actually you know make sense of it
rather than just spouting off a bunch of
buzzword it's like like it's like
watching Oceans 11 like somebody has
this talent you have the you have the
safe cracker you have the swaave leader
and now you always have the the the
genius hacker every movie has a genius
hacker oh there's always some young
person Tyrus oh let's have a genius
hacker I'm I'm picking up you don't like
the genius Hacker no because it's in
every I feel you I hate the British
Science all they do is like they run
into a roadblock in the movie and they
and they instead of like coming up with
a real answer they go let's give it to
what's it he goes like this we're in
they always do this yeah we're in and
then if that doesn't
[Applause]
[Laughter]
work
and if that doesn't work the British
scientists will solve it for you yes
exactly no have you heard British people
talk lately they're stupid
yeah I always laugh at when you hear
culture we need to incorporate culture
yeah the Navy has a culture it has a
tradition and you either get involved
with it or you leave I feel like the
whole point of is is to keep unqualified
people not fired mhm so you don't worry
about doing the job we just need the
numbers to put you in there because can
you just
imagine you have a bunch of equity hires
working the landing
strip on the ship in a fog storm you got
missiles shooting at people and Major
Tom is like Ground Control I'm coming in
hot I got one engine left ground control
my pronouns are him they herbs say it no
my other engine's out my other engine's
out until you say my pronouns I'm
[Laughter]
boom I'm the first to do it so it's not
my fault I just killed one of our own
crew members because he didn't have time
to tell me my damn pronouns instead of
doing my job that's the that's the
really scary thing I don't give a damn
what color you are all I care about is
how competent you are and that's what we
should all care about all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else